Someone once said that the best way
to learn about a city is
to leave your hotel room
and meet the locals.
You guys have been friends for how long?
Couple years?
Yeah.
How do you refer to each other?
If you're two Australians
do you just say
hey, mate?
Or you can add O on the end of their name.
So, you could be.
He's Jonathan,
becomes John-o.
Johno.
And what's your name?
Jim becomes Jim-o.
Jimo, would I be Conan-o?
Oh yeah, Con-o.
I'd be Con-o.
If you're Gary, it's Gaz-o.
All right, I'm gonna do something.
I'm gonna sit down and pretend we're
all three really good mates
that have known each other for four years.
I'm Con-o.
John-o.
Jim-o.
And let's just talk,
and use as much Australian
slang as you can.
Okay?
We'll try our best.
Hey!
Hey, Conan.
Sorry!
What the hell was that?
No!
We're gonna keep that in.
This is my first time on TV.
John-o.
Jim-o.
Jim-o and Con-o.
Con-O.
Do you think you got that this time?
I got it this time.
Hey, John-o!
Con-o!
Hey!
Nice to meet you.
Con-o.
Did you say nice to meet you?
Yeah.
No, we've been friends for years!
(laughing)
I said we've been friends for.
What is with him?
What's with John-o?
Listen.
We just need
to warm up to you.
We have been friends
for years.
We share a flat together.
Been ages, you're right.
It's been ages, we've done it all.
Okay, we've done it all.
Okay?
(laughs)
I've been in jail for a little bit.
Okay?
And we don't wanna talk about what I did.
Right.
I don't think I really did it,
but they say I did.
Here we go.
(laughing)
Hey, John-o!
Con-o, how are you doing?
Hey!
How was Long Bay?
Oh, Long Bays!
Oh mate, how lucky are we?
Huh?
You didn't have a surf recently?
Ah, surf.
Oh, yeah.
Good on ya.
(laughing)
Did you ride any barrels down there?
Oh, barrels!
(laughing)
Oh, yeah, yeah.
You get out through the barrel and--
Barrels, right through the barrels.
before you know it, you're in a billabong.
Um-de-bumbdy-billabong.
Um-de-bumbdy-billabong!
Suddenly, I'm a man at work
and then over there you got, you know.
Land down under,
that's what it's like.
Yeah, exactly!
But fair dinkum.
But hey, John-O!
You're a little mumsy with the tumsy.
What's going on?
(laughing)
Hey!
We gotta do this more often, huh?
Definitely.
Why aren't we doing this more often?
Group hug.
Bring it in.
You guys are the best.
Hey, sorry I was in prison.
(laughing)
It's not your fault.
Well, it actually was my fault.
Oh, it was your fault?
Yeah.
I thought the line was
it wasn't your fault.
No, I did it.
(laughing)
So, I've just been talking to people.
I like your country a lot.
Oh, thank you very much.
It's amazing, the people
are very laid back.
They're very nice.
I don't know.
Everything's quite regulated here, so.
It's just there are kind of laws
about absolutely everything.
Yes!
I've noticed that.
Here's the thing.
The ads they show us in America
about Australia are like,
Australia.
Come on down and party.
Who took this country full of pirates,
made you dress like this,
(laughing)
and be in bed at nine o'clock at night?
Have you ever been really drunk
when you're wearing this outfit?
No.
(laughing)
I want my school principal to know
that I've never been incredibly drunk
In fact,
while wearing this outfit.
you've never had alcohol, have you?
No, never.
And you know what?
Never.
You've never said a bad word?
A curse word?
No.
Never.
And you've never committed
any illegal act?
I have never sinned.
Never sinned.
I am pure in every sense of the word.
He is pure
I am a young child.
in every sense of the word.
He is a young child.
Yes.
You just keep talking,
and I'm gotta try and sound just like you.
Keep going.
Yeah.
So, we like to speak like this.
We like to speak like this.
Yeah, you from Penrith?
Yeah, you from Henry?
Penrith.
It's out in the western suburbs.
Yeah.
Penrith.
I'm running out of things to say.
I'm running out of things to say,
and then stop me.
I've ran out of things to say
about 14 years ago,
and I just keep going at it.
Nice to meet you, sir.
You too, sir.
It's an honor.
No, it was an honor for me.
Wanna get a selfie or something?
Yeah, alright.
(laughing)